hey potterheads when you think of harry
potter and his squad
do you picture daniel radcliffe rupert
grint and emma watson
well jk rowling had other ideas for
harry ron hermione and the gang
here's how the characters in the movies
should have looked
emma watson captures hermione's clever
bossy
fiercely loyal personality perfectly and
she's a pretty close match to jk
rowling's physical description too
with her big hair and brown eyes but
there are various tweaks that need to be
made to get hermione looking just how
the author described her
let's start with the hair when we first
meet hermione on the hogwarts express
she's described as having lots of bushy
brown hair
so let's frizz up that wavy mane and get
it even bigger
when you see hermione in the fully
illustrated version of the first book
her hair is actually pretty curly given
that jk rowling chose the illustrator
jim k
herself we can be pretty confident
that's how hermione should have looked
we also need to make her locks darker
emma's hair is
just too blonde to match the description
in illustration
thank goodness she discovered sleek
easy's hair potion in time for the yule
ball
next up is hermione's mouth her teeth
are way too regular to match the book's
description
rowling writes about the know-it-alls
rather large front teeth
sure madame pompfree shrinks her cursed
teeth in the fourth book
but they were never that big of the
movies in the first place
so we are taking these bad boys to bugs
bunny proportions
want a fun fact the director of the
first movie chris columbus did get emma
to try out fake teeth
but they quickly realized it was totally
impractical
when you think of ron weasley you think
of ginger hair right
and that's thanks to rupert grint but we
need to back up
in jk rowling's description of ron when
harry first meets him on platform nine
and three quarters
his hair is flaming red like all the
weasley boys were headed to hogwarts
that day
so we definitely need to brighten up his
mane we need to deal with ron's face now
he's described in the books as having
freckles so we need to add those in
as for his nose it needs to lengthen out
after all jk rowling points out that ron
has a
long nose all of these features match up
in the fully illustrated version of the
first novel
his eyes also need to be blue not rupert
grint's greeny blue
a fact that jk rowling revealed in an
interview
finally we need to deal with ron's body
he's shown as being average height and
average build in the first movie
but in the book he's described as being
tall thin
and gangling so let's lengthen out those
limbs
after all he's described as being almost
as tall as the twins already
he also needs big hands and feet yep
that's much more like it
jenny weasley only appears briefly in
the first film seeing off her brothers
on platform nine and three quarters
and bonnie wright certainly fits jk
rowling's description of being a small
girl
but we need to brighten up her hair like
her siblings she's described as being
redheaded
so let's get that hair away from the
brown end of the ginger spectrum and
right up to flaming red later on in the
book series she's described as having a
long mane of red hair
so we're going to give the youngest
weasley instant hair extensions
her bob in the first movie is gone in
favor of flowing locks
like her brothers ginny needs a whole
load of freckles
after all as draco explains all the
weasleys have red hair and freckles
illustrator jim k gives ginny a generous
helping of freckles in the illustrated
version of book four
he also gives her the correct eye color
and so we need to sort out those eyes
bonnie has blue eyes but ginny is
actually described in book two as having
bright brown eyes
so it's bye bye baby blues and hello
brooding browns
that's better in the books we first meet
neville longbottom on platform nine and
three quarters and then on the hogwarts
express
the only description we get of his
appearance is that he's a round-faced
boy
and matthew lewis is certainly a
round-faced boy to begin with
he has brown hair and is on the short
and plump side
but the actor changes massively over the
course of the films
in fact he says he had to wear a fat
suit as the films progressed
now jk rowling is pretty brief with her
physical descriptions of neville in the
books
however in an interview the author said
that to her
neville's short and plump and blonde but
what she loves about the books is that
people bring their own imagination to
the story to fill in the gaps
interestingly in the illustrated version
of the first novel
jim k gave neville brown hair but to be
true to rowling's vision we need to
switch up neville's hair color from
brown to blonde
we need to make him shorter and fatter
and we need to keep him that way
matthew lewis stop growing we're
finishing with the boy who lived
harry potter himself of course his most
defining feature is the very thin
scar on his forehead which was shaped
like a bolt of lightning as jk rowling
described it
that's closely followed by his black
hair and round glasses which were held
together with a lot of cello tape when
we first meet him in the book
but there's a major difference between
daniel radcliffe's version of harry and
the book's version
and that's the color of his eyes so
let's sort that out straight away
harry is described as having bright
green eyes
but daniel has blue they couldn't get
that detail right in the movie because
the actor was allergic to contact lenses
but as we're told time and time again
that harry's eyes are green
just like his mother's we need to
correct that pronto
as for his hair it's described in the
first book as being all over the place
so we need to ruffle up those locks and
give harry a messier do
harry's also described as having a thin
face so we need to lengthen that out
plus he's small and skinny for his age
so let's shrink him down even more
jk rowling would be so proud we hate to
say it but we're not sure victor crum
would have fallen for hermione if she
actually had those big teeth and big
hair in the movies
and as for daniel being allergic to
green contact lenses
he must have really impressed at his
audition to get past that hurdle
do you think the movie versions should
have stayed true to jk rowling's
descriptions in the books
sound off in the comments and let us
know thanks for watching